hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his work on the shortness of Life
Seneca has a number of points that he
wants to make about the pursuit of what
we think to be pleasure and so he's not
actually going after Hedonism as such in
the ways oh no pleasure isn't ultimately
the good he's actually willing to say
yeah you know pleasure a lot of people
want that I'm sure that you do too
there's nothing absolutely bad about
pleasure but the ways in which many
people try to seek out pleasure because
of the ways in which they
conceptualize pleasure make bad uses of
their time they exhaust the time that
they are given and so I think a really
good place to begin in this essay is
looking at something that he says in
chapter 13.
namely that
um
here we go peoples whose Pleasures
voluptates that's one of the words for
pleasure in in Latin put them to
considerable work
so Pleasures that require a lot of you
they're not at leisure nonsense
otiosi these are people who have free
time and their free time isn't really
like free time because they're so busy
with all the things that go along with
their pleasures and we can see a
contrast to this you know not everybody
who is is enjoying Pleasures is
necessarily doing that he talks in 7.9
about the person who devotes every
second of his time to his own needs and
organizes each day as if it were a
complete life proper use of time proper
understanding of time neither Longs for
nor is afraid of the next day for what
new kind of pleasure is there that any
hour can now bring everything's been
experienced everything enjoyed to the
full notice it he says enjoyed to the
full we you know it's not as if we have
to be dour and pleasureless in order to
make good use of our time no as a matter
of fact
using our time wisely will result in a
pleasant life among other things so he
goes on and he says uh you know for the
rest Fortune may make arrangements as it
wishes this person's life has already
reached safety addition can be made to
his life but nothing can be taken away
from it because they use this precious
resource of time wisely not by contrast
to that there's many people whose vices
swallow up their time as he says and
he's going to give you some examples of
this he says
that um
uh even if you live a thousand years and
more this will be compressed into the
mirror span of time those vices of yours
will swallow up any number of lifetimes
the span of time which good management
prolongs even though it naturally
hurries on must in your case Escape
quickly for you fail to seize it and
hold it back and you do nothing to delay
the speediest of things and so he says
among the worst cases I count those who
give their time to nothing but drink and
lust right so to the belly and to the
the genitals you could say right they're
just pursuing their bodily desires and
you know if you think about it you have
to spend a lot of time doing things in
order to enjoy these and they're not
great for your body but how much
enjoyment can you actually get out of
drinking every day or you know pursuing
sexual activities with different people
all the time and he says other people go
astray in other Fashions think about
people who are greedy people who are
quick to anger people who busy
themselves with unjust hatreds or Wars
scrutinize every moment of these
people's lives notice how much time so
once again the work that they have to do
how much time they spend on their Ledger
keeping how much on setting traps or
fearing them how much on cultivating
others or being cultivated by others how
much I'm giving or receiving bail how
much on dinner parties which themselves
have become business right they can't
even enjoy themselves at a party you see
that their Affairs whether good or bad
allow them no time to draw breath again
the same point they're not at leisure
they're not enjoying themselves fully in
the pleasures that they are pursuing and
it gives a whole bunch of examples of
leisure consuming Pleasures uh there's
there's a number of interesting ones
that he is going to bring up one of
these is going on vacation right he
talks about country Retreats on their
couch what we call a staycation right in
the midst of their Solitude their
troubling company for themselves it's
not leisurely but idle preoccupation
they're idle but they're preoccupied
occupants with all of these things that
they have to do and you see people like
this they go on vacation they're always
complaining nothing's ever the way it
needs to be they talk it up later oh I
went to this place on a cruise you know
and then they forget about the fact that
they didn't actually enjoy themselves on
the cruise and they were one of those
difficult passengers
he talks about arranging collections now
I don't think that too many of us can
relate to arranging with meticulous
attention to detail Corinthian bronzes
but we might think about other things
that we collect and want to show off
think about the proverbial nerd who has
all of the action figures in their
packages can't take them out and play
with them because then they would lose
their value but they have them in the
display case or people who collect other
kinds of figurines right you know or
produce entire towns of buildings I've
seen that sort of thing people collect
anything and everything you can even do
it virtually on your computer or on your
phone remember Pokemon collect them all
right that is uh you know that one
actually got people out you know chasing
them around using an app
that is not actually leisure time that's
turned into work because of the mindset
that people bring
uh getting into sports now he uses the
example of wrestlers and you know going
to the wrestling ring watching boys
brawling and then people who actually
have teams who separates the troops of
his own wrestlers into pairs of the same
age and skin color and you know this is
just again taking your time and throwing
it away you know worrying about what
your team's record is uh you know did
they change the quarterback how's the
new person gonna do all of these things
that people obsess about when it comes
to sports or even things that aren't
truly sports but are leisured
occupations like golf for example people
can just get obsessive about this sort
of thing and it's it's really not worth
it unless you can just enjoy it and
don't worry about all of these Myriad
details
obsession over appearance now he talks
about going to the barber right getting
your sh your beard shaved just right
having them arrange your hair
we have entire Industries catering to so
much else you know get your nails done
get your cosmetic surgery done so your
nose goes the right way get some tattoos
get your tattoos removed all of these
trivialities that people think are fun
and enjoyable wind up turning into work
for so many people right not just work
for the people that are doing it work
for the people who are enjoying it
they're perhaps depriving themselves of
genuine Pleasures focusing on music
something that we do indeed many of us
take great pleasure in he says what
about those who are absorbed in
composing listening to learning songs
The Voice who's best and simplest flow
is naturally straightforward they twist
into sinuous two turns of the most
feeble crooning their fingers are always
snapping in time to some song they carry
in their head when they've been asked to
attend a serious and even sorrowful
matters you can overhear them quietly
humming a tune and then here he reflects
and again says something similar this is
not uh Leisure but idle occupation it's
keeping them busy when you have an ear
worm that you can't get rid of that
could be like that
hosting parties parties are supposed to
be a fun time you know the Romans were
really into dinner parties and feasts
and banquets and stuff like that we like
all sorts of parties
it's very easy to get quite obsessed as
a host about you know all the little
things that have to be arranged and
making sure that everybody's having a
good time and to not have a good time
yourself as a result to get worked up to
get uh agitated to get anxious and upset
and that deprives you of pleasure he
also talks about people focusing on what
we'll just call trivia he brings up
matters of literary questions right and
some of these would be like is the same
person the author of both The Iliad and
the Odyssey or you know how many rowers
did Odysseus have but he also talks
about like history and people do get
quite obsessive about this you know a
few days ago I heard someone mentioning
which Roman general had been the first
to do what Julius was the first to win a
battle at Sea curryist and taught us the
first to parade elephants in a Triumph
and you know Seneca basically saying who
cares this is not stuff that actually
matters that is worth obsessing over I
mean I suppose if you're a historian and
that's your job sure but a lot of these
people who are you know
history Buffs or political junkies or
stuff like that they're just finding
ways to occupy themselves and waste the
time that they have with what are
essentially
disconnected details that have nothing
to do with their own lives you know
triviality is the things that we get
trivia from and what is the result of
all this there's a lot of people who
create for themselves and inability to
really enjoy the things that they think
are Pleasures so you know he talks
in chapter 16 about people who've been
waiting for this great thing to happen
and then he says the time of actual
enjoyment is short and fleeting
it's made far shorter by their own fault
they desert one pleasure for another and
cannot persist steadily in any one
desire their days aren't long but are
hateful yet on the other hand how short
seem the nights that they spend
converting with say prostitutes are
drinking right so there's a lot of
people who like you know they they work
them oh this is going to be so great
when I go to this concert and a
concert's over and you spend most of
your time getting there hanging out in
the parking lot walking in lines the
band plays for an hour and a half now
you got to get it get out to your car
get through these long lines of traffic
was it worth it for the experience that
you had was it really that Pleasant was
it what you built it up to be same thing
with you know oh I'm going to go out on
a date with this person and they're so
incredibly attractive and we're gonna
like hit it off and then we're gonna go
get a hotel room and get it on and it's
just gonna be amazing
and no one's probably not going to turn
out like that you know and even if it is
it's over right you you've lost it and
you move from pleasure to pleasure to
pleasure focusing on different ones not
actually enjoying what's in front of you
just as a side note I go to quite a few
band concerts and I'm always just amazed
at the fact that people have paid lots
and lots of money for these tickets and
we usually sit kind of far in the back
so we get to see everybody coming and
going and you see the same people in you
know getting out of their seats while
the band is playing and walking you know
all the way up the stairs and then they
come back and they've got four beers
that they've bought in cans which they
paid a lot of money for because it's not
cheap to do that and then they stumble
their way back down to their chairs and
they're like you know back listening to
the music now they've missed two songs
and they're slamming these beers because
they want to get as drunk as they can to
enjoy the party atmosphere and then
half an hour later bands still playing
here they come here comes Rum Dum drunky
again looking for some beers and you're
like why did you even bother coming to
this you could have just like watched a
DVD got yourself a 12 pack and slammed
all those beers at home you would have
had just about as good of a time you
know people do this in all different
ways they allow their Pleasures to
interfere with their Pleasures they
don't manage them well so that creates
an inability to enjoy other inabilities
are created by uh being anxious and
Disturbed he says
the very moment when people are
rejoicing
the agitated thought steals in on them
how long will this last
how long will I get to experience this
pleasure that I was seeking this entire
time
that ruins the pleasure he says it is
this feeling that has caused Kings to
weep over their own power the extent of
their prosperity gave them no pleasure
but the prospect of its eventual end
terrified them why is this the case
Seneca tells us he says they don't rest
on stable causes but they are disrupted
as frivolously as they are produced
these people are wretched because
they're subjecting themselves to
Fortune to Randomness to the way the
world Works which means that sometimes
you're up sometimes you're down right he
says the greatest blessings cause
anxiety Fortune is no less why wisely
trusted than when it at its most
advantageous to maintain Prosperity we
need fresh prosperity and other prayers
are to be offered instead of those that
have already turned out well everything
that comes our way by chance is unsteady
the higher our fortunes rise the more
susceptible they are to falling
but what must inevitably collapse gives
no one pleasure so the life of those who
acquire through hard work what they must
work harder to possess is pretty ratchet
and brief
he also talks about new preoccupations
replacing older ones so if we realize
this about one particular pleasure oh I
used to really enjoy drinking but can't
really do that anymore you know I'm
getting older the hangovers are worse
maybe I'll start gambling instead or
I'll just watch TV all day long you know
all of these sorts of things that people
do and he says new preoccupations take
the place of Old Hope arouses New Hope
ambition or new ambition they don't look
for an end to their wretchedness but
change the cause of it they don't learn
the lesson which is that you can really
only enjoy yourself you can really only
have those Pleasures if you're not
having to work too hard to get them or
to keep them or to prolong them so these
are some really important lessons I
think that Seneca has for us about you
know our own pursuit of pleasure and how
we arrange our life how we spend our
most precious commodity time in order to
hopefully attain them sometimes not even
managing to do that when we arrive at
the point where we're supposed to be
enjoying our Pleasures so this allows us
to place the pursuit of pleasure into
proper perspective